[Music]
hi are you the actor Andy Samberg I am
I'm a big fan man oh thank you very much
hey I got a question for
you you want to get
in Thomas Walcott single no children no
dependence job is Network management
physically
fit guess they're not too strict about
that one I'm joking this is kind of
serious
though you have been selected to partake
in the biggest reality show in the dark
web there will be people trying to kill
you the hunters what are you talking
about there people trying to murder
me oh [__] very much son you will have
30 days to survive you will only be
killed when you are alone so let me get
this straight you cannot touch me if I'm
with someone and then I get a million
dollars
what are you doing what are you doing
man why' you leave my side I didn't take
a [__] why didn't you wake me up and
bring me with you because I'm taking a
[__] let's
play what the [__] is this this is James
my new friend he B me to Shadow him you
cannot have this person sleeping in
Mom's house are you going to Shadow me
no are you going to Shadow me no sh are
you going to Shadow me I don't want to
take away James's
job this is going to end badly aren't
there other people playing the game who
could hang out with you just say it
you're not going to no I'm not going to
murder you are you going to murder me no
I want to be on the same team is you you
want to spend all our time together
after knowing me for 5 minutes let's
[__] win
[Music]
together they can't kill us if we're
together right okay good night I hope no
one murders either of
you wake up you are not as safe as you
think you
are
hi
[Applause]
guys where are you playing the game I
guess I did it cuz I want to be around
people more I think we did it for the
same reason I don't want to burst your
bubble but the game is a comedy how's it
a comedy they're trying to [__] kill
[Music]
us I it
all
get in the
car You' been having fun did you just
ask if I was having fun um yes
[Music]
no